e e
thank you um welcome everyone to
legislative
Administration uh a couple of quick
bookkeeping notes I was planning on
welcoming our new our new representative
to our committee um Jennifer Mel bomb um
but I don't see her so I hope maybe
she'll pop in later um we do so we have
a
replacement uh for the rest of the term
which is probably one more meeting um um
with
uh uh and taking the place of
Representative Dolan for the rest of the
session um aside from that uh we're at
past 10 o'clock so I
will recognize um co- co-prime sponsor
um uh represent uh Senator Susi um for
Senate Bill
605 welcome to the legislative
Administration thank you very much
chairman members of the committee for
the record I'm Donna Susi I represent
Senate District 18 five Wards in the
city of Manchester in the town of
Litchfield um this was a a late bill
that Senator Bradley and I the Senate
President worked on together um he
unfortunately has another 10:00 hearing
so we met in the elevator and um I hope
that I can do it justice um as probably
many of you are aware uh the legislative
Ethics Committee has released some
advisory
opinions um regarding when someone
should recuse
themselves the first opinion led to a
great deal of discussion amongst our
members some concerns
about making sure that individuals had
Clarity and
Direction uh about when they should
recuse themselves from certain votes so
that led to some work with our Senate
legal council to draft the bill that is
before you today
um it is our belief that recusal is
something that we should as legislators
take very seriously and consider when
we're looking at issues before us and
the potential impact they have on us as
individuals the language before you is
taken primarily from the IRS code which
has certain Provisions um that I will
outline in just a moment about what
substantial influences and I think
that's really one of the issues um we
can all come up with I'm sure some
examples where something is really
attenuated somebody is employed by a
company but really has no influence over
the decisions the company makes I mean
they may be somebody who is a custodian
for a a major employer there may be
someone who works in bill
they have no influence over the decision
making and I think what our focus is was
to really narrow down those instances
where someone has a truly substantial
interest so I would call your attention
to um the paragraph begins on line 13
and then you will see it outlines three
items starting on line
16 um about what substantial interest is
one is that excuse me I'm Excuse me the
recusal the substantial interest portion
that I I just pointed you to uh you
would have to be someone it defines who
that person is so somebody who's a
voting member of the governing body one
of the executives so the president chief
officer Treasurer or Chief Financial
Officer someone who does have a lot of
authority over the company the recusal
portion is actually the paragraph before
begins on line seven um and the
circumstances start with line n so
recusal in a situation where somebody
receives Financial remuneration from the
organization so paid from the
organization holds a position to
exercise substantial influence over it
and the organization has Lobby testified
or otherwise attempted to influence the
outcome of legislation it's not an or
it's all three so you would have
to be receiving funds from the
organization you would have to be
someone who substantially influences the
organization and someone would have had
to have testified or lobbied so we
believe the language is clear and very
significantly Narrows those instances
where a legislator should recuse
themselves from participation and
legislation um so with that I would be
happy to answer any question questions
that you may have Mr chairman uh to the
best of my ability thank you very much
for your testimony um yes
representative thank you for taking my
question
Senator based on line
16 since I am the chairman of the board
of Selectmen for the town of
Northumberland I wouldn't be able to
vote on anything that pertains to
municipalities because up on line
six six okay thank you uh the United
States the state of New Hampshire
counties within the state but
municipalities aren't included in there
and just because I'm a board member why
should I be
disqualified yeah thank you for that
question representative it is a good one
because I think that applies to a number
of people in our legislature I I will
get back to you with the specific
reference but I believe there is
actually a provision that exempts those
from government and Municipal
organizations that is another part of
the chapter um the issue if I just may
complete my answer part of the reason
this issue arose in the Senate is for
example we have three members of the
Senate that are employed by well two by
the university system one by the
community college system so the question
came up would those members be precluded
from voting on the budget since the
university system and others and there
was a legal determination made by our
Council which I believe was presented to
the Senate Ethics Committee and I see
former Justice and representative Gordon
here who can who's chair of that
committee who can explain um there is an
exemption for those situations that
already exists in the statute and if
that isn't clear from here once I give
you the site that's something that we
certainly would want to
exempt sure I'm
sure so would you have objections if
municipalities were added to line six
right after counties um I personally
would not okay um but I would I'm
speaking on my own behalf I would
obviously want to consult with the
Senate President as well as the prime
sponsor of the bill great thank you
further
questions I have a couple sure um if you
don't mind not at all um you may or may
not be aware uh this committee has been
working or struggling with this for
three years or so um and and one of the
things that we started coming to the
table with was the was the fundamental
question of whether we are trying to um
provide guidance to the legislator who
Maybe sitting in division three in the
middle of a row and trying to figure out
whether he has he or she has a problem
um with the bill that's before us and
without having a their attorney on speed
dial um having to answer whether they
should be recusing themselves from that
debate or not um and and judging that
against the idea of whether this is more
for the Ethics Committee
to um judge
individual opinions such as the one that
you mentioned earlier with uh with the
three
instructors um we're not we we kind of
come down on both sides of that issue
whether whether this is for the
legislator to to guide them or whether
it is for punitive purposes or or
judgmental purposes so that's where we
started I guess my first question is do
you feel that this legislation proposed
legislation puts us in a better category
with either of those one or the
other thank you representative Hill for
the question I I think it does a bit of
both I think it provides clear guidance
to the individual who is as you said
confronted with an issue and is trying
to work through whether or not they
should specifically recuse and as I said
they'd have to meet all three criteria
it's an and not an or um but I also
think that the statute does not
currently
provide um for the legislative Ethics
Committee to have very specific
statutory guidance as to when recusal is
clear so I I I think it does both it's
not an effort to try
to get people caught it's an effort to
try to better inform the individual
legislator and to the extent the
committee is rendering opinions about
whether or not somebody may have
violated the law I think having
something in statute is better than
simply relying upon um all of their
previous opinions and upon the
individual circumstances and as I said I
I do know that the chair of the
committee is here and I'm sure will'll
entertain those questions for you as
well and and we have questions for them
as well um beyond that
um I guess um where I'm uh well first of
all do you would you know if um attorney
Layman had uh went to the IRS
regulations um primarily or as a as a
second Source we in this committee we
went and looked at and riew viewed what
all of the other states do and how how
their wording is set up um I think I'm
safe in saying we didn't even look at
what the IRS determines um so can you
speak to why the IRS language was
preferable um actually I cannot speak
for him um all I can tell you is that
that was one of the references he
indicated was used in developing helping
us to develop this legis
ation um I I think I'll have a
conversation with with Rick later on
then um I wondered if if the
conversation or the question of whether
we would need to change any part of um
uh part two article 7 of The
Constitution where it talks about being
of council do you is that anything that
came up in the senate in any did not Mr
chairman okay because I notice in I
think it's page to
line we get to line 11 um where where
we're um tending to show no substantial
influence we've included attorneys in
there um and it would seem to me that
would run counter to part two article 7
where it specifically States being of
council well
I there are I think I would answer that
question in two ways um being of
council the way the Constitution
represents is is different than it's a
term of art used for currently um
the position an attorney might hold
within a firm there are those that are
of councel that are not you know
substantially influent but are
affiliated with the firm um I also think
with respect to attorneys um there are
as you know I'm sure well Mr chairman
having considered these issues before um
there are a number of other ethical
issues um regarding an attorney's
representation of their client and
further representation before the
legislature so that's something we would
need to consider as well I I I don't
think the Constitutional provision is
implicated here but certainly something
we we did not consider and would be Happ
to work with the
committee uh following up on that we it
seems that the
legislation gears more towards the
employer employee relationship um and
and judging by the fact that the I think
the last four or five of the of the
opinions that were rendered by the
Ethics Committee do Center in on that
employer employee
relationship um
did the senate or or in drafting this um
did was the consideration for those
those ethical considerations that are
occurring outside that relationship um
was that something
that you you seem to have focused only
on the employer or employee relationship
um is the rest of it fine as far as
you're
concerned well I think the rest of it if
you're referring to other professions I
think you're referring to those that
provide service to an employer or to the
organization as opposed to someone who
has direct authority over an individual
um actually I would say that what we
attempted to craft with the legislation
is something that would be clear that
there are many employees of
organizations that are not receiving
compensation aren't in a decision-making
position and aren't directly lobbying
that don't want to capture we only want
we want to try to narrow it to those
that truly would self benefit from their
participation in the legislation and
that's you know maybe maybe not as clear
in the language as you know we see it
but that was what we were attempting to
do Mr chairman was to try to focus in on
those individuals that are truly
substantially trying
to influence legislation that that would
then directly benefit
themselves thank you further questions
from seeing none thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman we'll see you in a
few minutes I guess
yeah uh chair would call um chairman
Representative Bob
Lynn member of the Ethics
Committee supports the bill with
reservations
so thank you good morning thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee um as
I indic as indicated on the note card I
I do support the bill but I do have some
reservations and um one of the
reservations I have and I I think it it
U goes to the question that was uh asked
by of the previous witness
um I like I like the
restrictions that the three uh uh
restrictions that uh uh Define when a
legislator should recuse himself that is
receives Financial re remuneration from
an organization holds a position to
exercise substantial influence over the
Affairs of the organization and the
organization has Lobby testified or
otherwise attempted to influence the
outcome of the official legislative
activity but my question is is sort of
the the the opposite of of the question
that you raised in other
words the I guess the question that I
have is if you have those three
conditions which I think are good
conditions then why would you exclude
from the definition of
organization the United States of
America the state of New Hampshire or a
county and I guess what I'm thinking is
is this we I know and these are the
because the advisory opinions are public
records we issued uh two advisory
opinions um that I was involved in one
one and a third one that I was not
involved in because I recused myself but
the two that that I was involved in we
dealt with uh uh uh Senator Andis and
Senator Carson and we said that their um
the fact that they were employed by the
university system in one instance and
the community college system in another
did not require them to recuse
themselves uh but but I guess the the
question i' have is
suppose they they were only working as
uh I believe Senator inis is a professor
at the University of New Hampshire and
uh Senator uh Carson I believe is a
part-time uh instructor at the Comm I
think the I think Nash Community College
but one of the community colleges anyway
but I I guess the question that it
seemed to me it would have made a big
difference is suppose that instead of
working instead of the position they
held they actually worked in the
Chancellor's office or something like
that and were and had some you know
involvement in the positions that the
University was going to take on matters
before the legislature I think our
outcome would have been you know that
would have been an a much different
situation and so you know I guess that I
would say um that's there if you're
going to have the the requirements of
being able to in uh exercise substantial
influence over an organization
then if you have that caveat why
wouldn't you
include employees of the state or the
federal government or or the counties um
so I you know I I would tend to say that
they that they should be covered um and
and and you know to to give just to give
an example I think which I I
think would would kind of go to the
question you you raised if
if for
example you are a selectman in the town
and so you have you know you have a
substantial authority over what what
kind of what position the town would
take and you receive compensation from
the town and the town is going to Lobby
in favor of some particular particular
measure before the
legislature I I guess the question that
I would ask is why would why should the
law say it's okay for you to do that
you're not you know you you don't have
to recuse yourself Bute and let's take
an I try to use a concrete example you
know the bill that was that we had quite
a debate on the question of like what um
whether um people who make substantial
requests for information under the
rights of no law do should they have to
pay for it I my my recollection is that
many municipalities were thought that
was a good idea um and there were a lot
of other people who thought it was a bad
idea but suppose that you know a
particular municipality the selectman in
that municipality think it's a great you
know we should be making people to pay
uh making people pay for that so that it
doesn't the burden doesn't fall in the
taxpayer um why should it be all right
for a selectman who has taken that
position and the um you know and
receives comp let's assume they receive
compensation for being a selectman um to
be able to to to vote on that but
suppose suppose that somebody from the
ACLU who you know who was very much
opposed to that legislation suppose we
had somebody in a in a you know in a
relatively high level position with the
ACLU who was also a
legislator this would prohibit that ACLU
member from from uh voting and it just
seems like there's a there's some
something of a disconnect there it it
seems to me either either both should be
prohib should be prohibited or both
should be allowed but I I have you know
it's I have some difficulty in
understanding why why you would draw
that distinction um now may you know
maybe this is just a
suggestion maybe an answer to that would
be to put some
compensation dollar limits in other
words I suspect that uh most Selectmen
in the state of New Hampshire are not
receiving high dollar compensation for
their services it would be it would be
very uh surprising to me if they were so
maybe it would be you know maybe one
solution might be to say you know um a a
cut off would be uh a a a a state
federal or Municipal Employee who is not
earning more than
some amount of money you know some
relatively low amount of money um and
that would be you know that would be a
basis for the distinction I I'm just I'm
just throwing that out as a possibility
I'm not saying that's necessarily the
the right answer but it's something to
think about
anyway thank you repes good morning um
good morning representative wall um you
have a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much for your testimony
today and for being here um you
mentioned selectman and not being paid
much but they are paid something and
Selectmen and communities have
tremendous power and influence as to
what goes on wouldn't that be vitally
important in terms of decisions that are
made here yeah no I I mean I I agree I I
guess you know the
the I I appreciate the the uh your
colleague's concern about do we want to
you know prohibit uh people who are are
are selectman for example our school
board members and also serve in the
legislature do we want to kind of
prohibit them from voting on things that
about which they have a lot of
information and a lot of knowledge you
know that's uh that that is the that
really is the crucial question um and I
think
the you know the other thing that I that
that would that concerns me as I said
before it's just the idea of balance it
I'm I'm I'm not sure that it it is a
good idea to sort of generally
exempt um state employees or federal
employees or County Employees um but and
as you point out if we're and that
that's another kind of
uh you know distinction that I'm not
sure I understand why if you were going
to
exempt federal employees state employees
and County Employees then why not
Municipal Employees I mean it just it
doesn't quite you know that that doesn't
there's a disconnect there it seems to
me um so anyway representative wall
follow Mr chairman thank you thank you
for that explanation so I hear you
saying it sort of depends on the
hierarchy of where you are in your
position or what influence you might
have in the organization to which you
belong I I think that's I think that's
right I mean I think I agree completely
with Senator Susi if some you know if
somebody is if if I'm you know if I work
for Amazon but my position is I'm the
you know I'm the chief custodian then I
think and I'm also in the legislature I
don't think that um it's very likely
that my um you know that I'm going to be
influencing the positions of the
organization I mean absent some you know
unless there's some
nefarious thing going on that they hired
me specifically to be you know the
really my real job is to be a lobbyist
for the for them but I'm I'm acting as a
you know as a chief custodian that's
probably pretty unlikely final question
followup thank you very much so what I
hear you saying is really up to the
individual and the individual's position
in terms of the issue that comes before
the legislature to determine how much
influence they might have on that par
particular subject and therefore they
would have to determine whether they
should recuse or not is that correct I
no I think that's right I think a lot of
this um as I've discussed on numerous
occasions with the chairman a lot of
this does depend on um you know
legislators exercising sort of
reasonable and good faith Judgment of
you know and I think we I think we can't
we can't get away from that that's
that's a a crucial part of
this thank you very
much representative
Tierney thank you for taking my question
representative okay there is a bill this
afternoon coming up it's SB 553
has to do with the p dip accounts and
that is the public deposit investment
pool according to what's written here I
would not be allowed to say anything I
would not be our Treasurer would not be
allowed to say anything and yet we're
the ones in the town who would have the
most ex uh knowledge of how those
accounts work all right the only ones
who could speak would would be the
opposing side the ones who want the bill
to pass would that be a fair way to run
that hearing yeah no that's a that's a
good point I guess the only question I
would have is I don't I don't know a lot
about that bill at least at this point
but the only question I would have is is
the for example has your town taken a
position on on this you know what I'm
saying is that is that or is that
something that was just follow up
I an answer to that uh basically yes the
treasurer is opposed to it our count
administrator is opposed to it and I'm
the chair of the board of Selectmen
right uh I'm opposed to it it it's not
allowing us to make as much money as
possible for the taxpayers so it's
making us violate our fiduciary
responsibility to the town right right
no I I mean I I I see what you're saying
I think I agree with you it's not you
know you you you have to have some you
have to have some balance I don't I
don't know exactly where the you know
where the line should be um if you know
the thing that would concern me is for
for example if the
if you know suppose I think maybe this
is a really unlikely situation but
suppose that you know someone pretty
high up in your uh police department in
the town let's say I take the police
department as an example but um was also
in the legislature and there was a bill
um dealing
with I don't know increasing uh pension
benefits for for uh for police officers
um you know there I don't know if the
and and if the you know if the town uh
um took a position that this was a great
idea um I don't know or or you know I
don't know what the that there it seems
to me it's a close
closer uh question about whether the
person should be voting on that um on on
that that's that's just an
example
I you indicated earlier that we do we
have had numerous conversations about
this um and I'm and I want to ask you
specifically about line six on page two
which um The Heading is facts and
circumstances um it was our original
intention in this committee to create
some kind of guidelin so that individual
employees would be able to make
um legitimate decisions for themselves
and decide whether they were on um the
correct side of this recusal issue or
not it seems to me the more that we
delve into this and the more we discuss
individual cases and the more we
review the ACT ual um ethics opinions
that have come forth from the Ethics
Committee it seems that these facts and
circumstances are becoming more and more
important and it almost it would seem
that each individual four of the 400
reps sitting in rep's Hall would need to
have um a review of their individual
facts and circumstances before they
could be confident of of their actions
and so I'm I guess my question for you
is does this legislation coming forth
from the
Senate coupled with your knowledge of
what the house passed on consent
calendar a couple weeks ago does this
move that ball
forward yeah I think I mean subject to
concerns yes
thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you very much for C thank you uh
chair would call um the chairman of um
the Ethics Committee uh The Honorable
Ned
Gordon welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee pleasure to be
here pleasure to have you thank
you uh my name is Ned Gordon I do chair
the Ethics Committee I'm from
Bristol a former
legislator I um I support the bill I
think it U clarifies the standard for
recusal I think there are circumstances
where it is obvious to most people
including the public that recusal is
appropriate and we should have at least
in our statutory guidelines a standard
for that and currently we don't if you
were to read the guidelines there is
nothing that mentions recusal at
all but again there are circumstances
where it appears has appeared obvious to
the Ethics Committee and I think to many
that recusal is is an appropriate
outcome and I think ultimately it was
contemplated in our constitution in the
1700s that a recusal that there are
circumstances where it's not appropriate
for a legislator to act uh and to act as
a legislator on certain matters when
they have a personal
involvement so uh I think this uh the
standards that are set forth in this
legislation pretty much mirror The
Advisory opinions that we have been
issuing particularly with regard to
people receiving Financial
remuneration and whether or not that
organization has actively participated
in uh influencing the outcome of
legislation and in our in our more
recent opinions particularly the last
opinions that we've had you'll see that
I think we've all also Incorporated what
is included here as sort of the third
prong of the test and that is whether or
not the person who is employed in the
organization has substantial influence
over the
organization so I think it sets forth a
standard I think it's consistent with
what we've been doing and I think uh
having it in statute makes a lot of
sense I do have a comment with regard to
uh
the I I fully agree with the portion of
the bill that says that these three
criteria are deemed to be having
substantial influence voting members of
the governing body presidents executive
officers
treasurers but I think my my only
concern is sort of a statutory thing and
this comes from being a lawyer I think
and a judge and that is if I were
reading through the statutes and I read
that first I might get the impression
that that those are the only things that
have substantial
influence and then you go to the next
section and that talks about the facts
and circumstances which constitute
substantial influence I might just
reverse those and put the facts and
circumstances of substantial influence
first and then put persons having uh
persons having these particular roles
are deemed to have substantial influence
after that so there wouldn't be any
confusion with that that
regard with regard
to uh uh representative Lyn's
concerns um I guess I share some of
those concerns because I believe that
there would be circumstances where
people
do um uh are involved in governmental
matters where I think if you were
looking at it as a member of the public
he would say it would not be appropriate
for them to vote on things so if the
financial officer of the University
system was a
legislator and was involved in
developing the budget for the University
system and promoting it here I don't
think they should be voting on it so um
but if I was a selectman and I'm just
one of 250 towns in the state that feels
a particular way
I really don't think that that would
disqualify you from having an opinion as
to whether a lot legislation should be
passed or not passed but that's my I I
have to say uh first of all that uh we
we talked about whether or not this is
uh informative for legislators or
whether it's intended to be punitive I
can tell you that the Ethics Committee
doesn't View itself is punitive in the
lease um it rules on complaints and when
it's appropriate we'll act on complaints
but over the 30 years the ethics
committee's been here there have only
been less than a handful of times when
we've actually recommended punishment
for legislators what we've done our very
best to do is to inform legislators to
uh make sure that uh things are done
appropriately
but once in a while you get a
circumstance where you see it's just
appropriate for somebody to recuse
themselves I mean and we see it the
public sees
it they if we had and you know these are
all you know public opinions the Doug
lay opinion for example you know it
pretty clear you know a circumstance you
can't
be an Essence lobbying and voting on the
same same things um and more recent opin
iions that have come out it's pretty
obvious so it's pretty obvious of
somebody but we're not going out there
looking as a police force for people to
punish
for their bad behavior what we're trying
to do as our very best is to educate and
make sure that uh when the public looks
at our legislature they see people who
are ethical and who are uh doing their
very best to be honest and to serve the
state well
I think it was me that brought up the
word uh punishment and I think it would
have been better to say perhaps that it
was a tool of adjudication it's a y it's
whether it's
for in informational purposes for the
legislature or whether it helps the
Ethics Committee to determine um whether
there's a violation or not I think
that's better um you have a minute or
two for questions if there are any yep
I'll do my best representative wall
who's also on
the thank you Mr chairman and thank you
very much Mr chairman for being here um
you mentioned slackman and positions
they may or may not take because uh
we're one of over 200 towns in the OR
municipalities in the state this may go
back to when you were on Judiciary we
had um a lot of
landlords who were on the Judiciary
Committee and were taking or making
votes um on certain issues that were the
landlord tenant things thinking it
directly affected them would that be a
more sensitive situation than Selectmen
being parts of all the communities in
the state I mean there are landlords all
over the state so how would this work
with landlords I I think it's a similar
circumstance that there are
landlords ultimately will be affected by
legislation just like municipalities
will be affected by legislation but
they're not being paid to be there to
lobby and influence the legislation
itself and so I don't think that there's
a necessity for them to recuse
themselves further questions um I have
one or two um as far as the municipality
we seem to have centered in on
Selectmen but there are plenty of other
um influencers within the within a
municipality um you know Fire Chiefs
police Chiefs um would would that with
those same circumstances that same
discussion occur um we see often times a
a uniform um come through and testify on
on things um we have plenty of officers
that are um legislators is it all going
to fall down onto this facts and
circumstances situation do you think
yeah
I do
um well I don't think you you can make a
decision just based upon a
generalization you know that's why you
need the standard to apply to this
particular case
but just because you are a firefighter
or a police officer and you take a
position and in and of itself I don't
think that's going to disqualify you
what disqualifies you is if you're
getting paid to do it
basically so just to clarify if you're
getting paid to testify you're saying
rather than the outcome of the
legislation that you're testifying on
pay isue right I mean if you're a
firefighter and you feel strongly about
some something and you come here I don't
think anybody is going to find that you
should be disqualified or that you had
need to recuse but if you are paid to do
so then certainly you would be required
to
recuse um so a quick just clarification
on that so if um if for example we have
a a piece of legislation dealing with um
with the retirement system and it would
be clear that the firefighters um or any
of group two or group one benefit from
that
legislation where where are they in that
in that scenario um where would would a
a legislator who is also a firefighter
Andor a policeman Andor um
County just being just being part of an
organ organization wouldn't disqualify
you but I think you'd have to apply the
standard as to whether or not you were
um had substantial influence over the
effort to affect the legislation I
see uh any further questions seeing none
thank you very much I'm sure this won't
be the last conversation we have on the
topic we've had many conversations have
thank you very much
um I have only one additional pink card
um and that comes from Eric payer um
Power I'm sorry um who supports the bill
and is asking for two minutes from the
school district governance
Association welcome to legislative
Administration thank you committee
members honorable chair my name is Eric
power I'm come from the town of Brook
line I'm also the president of the
school district governance Association
of New Hampshire which is an all
volunteer volunteer
organization Statewide I just want to
bring up a couple of points to consider
um with this um legislation so I also
previously schooled uh served on the
school board Hollis Brookland
Cooperative school board for three years
and I got paid $450 a year but I was on
the governing body of a school board so
keep that in mind when you're looking at
renum renumeration um I think that
select boards um I also serve on the
planning board in Brooklyn uh I don't
get paid for that right now but who
knows that could change in the future
but I think if people are serving in
these in a school board and
municipality um and getting some sort of
stipend and Selectmen tend to get more
than school board for whatever reason
but some upper limit maybe
$5,000
$10,000 that if you're get financial R
renumeration you're not going to get
rich from legislation the the select
board members aren't going to get rich
school board members aren't going to get
rich so kind of consider that that just
saying you get a dollar would would
would fill that square so or my wife's
of State Rep as you as some folks might
know she would be disqualified from it
because I got a dollar so we don't want
to do that so we probably want to put
some um upper limit because if some sort
of legislation passes
um and you were involved you don't want
to have to come back to it and you're
not going to get rich by um being a
select board member or a school board
member if some sort of legislation
passes so I would say that um also in uh
you know line six talks we talked about
you talked about potentially adding in
uh municipalities but I would also maybe
you would want to use a term like
political subdivision because that would
cover school districts that would cover
Village districts that would cover
municipalities that would cover cities
it would cover more in that uh aspect I
think and that would be important um I
do think it's really important that you
know you have the three conditions that
have to be met and I think it needs to
be clear maybe it's clear enough in
there because I wouldn't want my wife to
be um having to recuse herself she's in
the same household as me if I if those
don't all meet so the number one
wouldn't be met because I don't get paid
by my organization um but we want to
make sure that you keep that because I
think it's important for all three and I
think the main thing you're trying to
look at here is is the individual going
to enrich themselves or is their spouse
or family member going to enrich
themselves are they going to get some
Financial direct Financial benefit uh
and I agree this is a very challenging
area there's a lot of circumstances you
got to look at but if you're putting
sort of these top level uh guidelines
out there I think we you know I have a
lot of people in sgaa that are
Schoolboard members and budget committee
members some are paid most of them are
paid some sort of stipend um we wouldn't
want them to have be caught by this uh
legislation so having some upper limit I
think makes a lot of sense and um
otherwise I I support the bill I think
it's a good thing to give some guidance
to our legislators to know when to
recuse themselves so thank you I'll take
any
questions thank you um further
questions I have one
um in in a lot of these conversations
we've had um it talks about uh real or
perceived conflict
um you were the only member so far to
have spoken from the public um is is
there a perception um that there are
there are um items that uh legislators
need to be aware of from the purposes of
conflicts for the for the sake of
conflicts I think as you know as a
member of the public and looking at this
I think you want to see how Direct is
that benefit you know I think a
firefighter coming in to speak about
group two or group one teacher coming in
um I think that that's it's such a big
population that they they they're
entitled to and as some of your other
members have said in the committee a lot
of the folks that are speaking have
subject matter expertise more than
others so if you really want to as
legislators make an informed decision I
think you need to be able to take that
in and is that influence or not it's
sort of like state employees are they
allowed to take positions on bills while
they're on duty or not but they are
subject matter experts so I think you
have to balance that but I think you
have to look at the circumstance that
are you if you're if you're the
treasurer of the University system and
you're then on finance committee the
finance division two or three whichever
one does that obviously that from a
member of the public I would say why is
why are they on their setting their
budget to get some more money but if
it's a if it's it depends how direct the
benefit is and how big the group is I
think is the big from a member of the
public that's what would upset people
more than anything um but we don't want
to set legislation here that would catch
people getting stipend from being able
to help form uh legislation here up here
whether they're and and or their their
spouse you know they might not even be
the person keep that in mind you have a
family member that lives with you so you
want to keep that in mind but I think
that's the main thing the public would
be like to see is that people aren't
enriching themselves by passing
legislation I think that's kind of the
bottom line here people get might get
more power is that is that something
people worry about I don't think people
worry about that as much as somebody
getting
enriched thank you thank
you further comments seeing none thank
you very much I have no other pink cards
if there's anyone else in the audience
that would like to comment I'm perfectly
happy to take a pink card seeing none I
will close the hearing on Senate Bill
you
the time being 10 minutes of 11 um we
will open up Senate Bill 331 recognize
well are you Senator waters are you the
prime sponsor of this I am I'm ready I
recognize Senator David Waters
um Prime
sponsor for Senate Bill 3c1 welcome
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee good to see you all I'm
Senator David Waters from district for
to introduce Senate Bill 331 uh relative
to certain historic commemorations as
you will see the uh bill has two parts
um one is as is customary as I explained
uh to direct that the joint legislative
historical committee accept a uh
portrait of U former Senator Martha poer
Clark and the second part of the bill um
Again by procedures we've done before um
ask that bottle uh liquor bottle revenue
from the Craner bottles be directed
towards the American Revolution cester
Centennial and I'm going to call 250th
Commission if you don't
mind and I will speak about that as as
well um so as to the uh uh first part um
I will say we have other member of The
Joint legislative historical committee
here um we've made an effort over many
years to curate forits to represent
people have made contributions to the
state you see the results all around uh
the halls and um is brought forward a
proposal to include a portrait of the
former Senator Marth Clark um
and such a portrait was already
commissioned we have it and uh so we'd
like to have this legislation to direct
the historical committee to accept the
gift and to find a place for it on our
state house walls uh let me note as well
that the committee has made major
efforts over the last several years to
kind of rationalize and organize the
portrait collection throughout the halls
of the uh of the state house um and to
move some things around and to deal with
the governor's portraits coming flowing
out of the governor's office as as the
time is and and then accepting other
other ones and doing some rearranging
bringing things down to the first four
that ought to be on the uh first four um
making clearer the designation of the
Civil War area that the uh American
revolutionary and War of 1812 area and
so on and so forth and in that process
it means that we have been able to um
ensure that there is space available for
subsequent fors in the uh in the future
um we will hear uh I think from others
about the extraordinary record of
Senator fer Clark and I I just would
like to add to that um having worked
with her for many years that you know
it's hard to drive around the state
without seeing things that have been the
uh Touch of Senor Fuller Clark whether
it's an environment elip the
planetarium um and just countless
countless bills uh as a House member and
as a and a senate member and I think as
the sponsorship of this bill reflects um
she was an extraordinar bipartisan
legislator whether she was in the house
or the Senate and I think that was long
recognized about her and that's why the
sponsorship you will see uh reflects
that as well so just to summarize on
that um this is the usual form that we
do um the state does not ever does not
pay for portraits whether it's the
governor or not uh privately raised
funds create the the portrait and then
um we need to have a bill that uh
instructs the uh joint legislative
historical committee to accept the the
portrait and find a place for it now the
second um part of the bill I I just you
know I'm very excited about it's great
fun because we got a 250th anniversary
coming up of the uh of the American
Declaration of Independence and um you
know these anniversaries keep coming up
don't they we did the the bicentennial
of the state house we had the Civil War
um and you know this is just an
opportunity for us to celebrate New
Hampshire history um and uh about 20 no
no I'm sorry about 12 years ago we
recommenced the historic liquor bottle
program which had kind of been suspended
for many years and reestablish that to
about once a year have the Liquor
Commission design uh a bottle and the
funds that are raised from that have
been going uh first uh they were
directed entirely to the hall of flat
and the preservation of the Hall of
flags and that great history that's
represented there and we've done a lot
of work the you know new film on the
glass new the new uh new stained glass
over the the front door and um any kind
of preservation and conservation that
needs to be there and then we expanded
um that that fund's use so that it can
include other historical uses as as well
um what we have done uh since the
reestablishment of this is to direct the
um funds from a liquor bottle that is
issued in relationship to a particular
historic event to that events coffers we
did that with the um Vice centenal of
the state house so we had the bottles
the couple bottles there that the
revenue um and it can run from like 50
to 880,000 potentially depending on the
bottle depending on the marketing um and
so now with the 250th anniversary uh
with the establishment of the C
Centennial commission which against some
are are on uh the
commission uh affirmed the idea that if
we could do that for them because they
had no funding uh from the state when
the commission was established and need
to raise their funds that this would be
a way to do that so the bill established
a fund form and then directs the uh
revenue from the bottles that are
created uh to commemorate the uh
Declaration of Independence um that that
those funds will come in we'll be able
to use them um for the celebrations were
directed to do one is about um the uh
Fort Constitution and there going big
plans coming up for Fort Constitution uh
and so this commission is supposed to
work on that and we're also supposed to
plan appropriate historical events at
the at the state house and maybe else
mostly the state house as we did with
the bicentennial the the state house um
for July 4th uh you know those days
around July 4th of of 20 26 and um so
that that's the two parts uh Mr chairman
and i' be GL to take any questions thank
you Senator um are there further
questions representative wall thank you
you didn't bring the portrait no I've
got a little picture of it if you'd like
to see it's a beauty office yeah thank
you um my question is um the historic
and I for disclosure I'm Vice chair of
that committee I'm also an assister Cal
committee so bear with me um so I know
where it's going thank you um so um
regarding the portrait so that the
historical committee can accept it and
then decide what to do with it where to
hang it is that your intent yeah thank
you for the question that's what we
always do great thank you along that
line um I wanted to make sure or that
you would be all right with the the line
in that in the bill itself speaks to the
state house um it's my understanding
they may decide that it's more
appropriate in the L rather than the
state house so um that would be left up
to them
correct I think so um you know and thank
you for your question because some of
the things we've done the last few years
you may notice that we um accepted some
portraits uh that were at the over at
the Supreme Court right and we now have
them in um room 100 and uh we have put
um some portraits over into the
Legislative Office bu
right um you know I I I think an
argument might be made and we'll discuss
this on the committee that given um her
stature and the need in some ways to
recognize um you know we have Donna side
Tech hanging up there and and I think
it's a a good thing for us to be able to
have the public come in and and see the
women who have contributed and we have
dudly Dudley so wherever wherever is a
good space for it Mr chairman great yeah
thank you the flexibility is
there where are the comments seeing none
thank you very much Senator and I do
have a little zerox but want to look at
it chair would call uh I can just hold
it up there's the zero ah there you go
not too big nice Port bigger than that
though um Senator
sus thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
once again I'm Donna sus representing
Senate District 18 um I just wanted to
highlight a couple things since my my
colleague really spoke very well to the
magnitude of the legislation um I want
to speak specifically to the portion
about the portrait of Senator Fuller
Clark which if you are interested in
seeing the actual portrait is in my
office in State House 120 you are
welcome to come see it um she was first
elected in 1990 to the house and served
on the municipal and County government
committee I know this because we were
first elected together and served on
that committee together um but Senator
Fuller Clark's leadership in both the
house and the Senate um was truly
distinguished she ultimately served in
the position of Senator protm uh the
assistant to the Senate President but
her body of work just in the legislature
alone is really quite extraordinary um
she had 113 bills on which she was the
Prime sponsor that were signed into law
623 bills that were signed into law that
she
co-sponsored um but apart from the the
breath of legislation alone I think
Senator Fuller Clark probably will when
history books are written be known as a
Distinguished Citizen uh because of the
philanthropy of both her and her husband
and because of the extraordinary impact
she's had on the lives of people
throughout the state of New Hampshire um
through various positions um one of the
things that my colleague didn't mention
but that I think is really important for
the record um the artist who painted the
portrait is Ralph Stony Jacobs U Stony
Jacobs is a resident of Whitefield New
Hampshire and he has uh done numerous
portraits um Senator Shaheen and Senator
uh Excuse excuse me Senator Shaheen and
Governor Lynch's portraits were done by
Stony Jacobs there are portraits that
hang throughout the United States um he
is a a really renowned artist but as I
said is a you know a resident of
Whitefield New Hampshire so not only is
the portrait of a local citizen but it
was also uh painted by a local artist um
and I would just in closing say right
now of the 213 portraits that hang in
the state house and the complex nine of
them are women um so I think it would be
great to increase that percentage by
accepting this additional portrait so
with that I close my testimony and happy
to answer any questions you may
have thank you Senator uh other further
questions thank you very much see none
thank
you for
thank you very much for uh tolerating
this uh we now call Jennifer
Goodman and Jennifer is in support of
the bill she represents the New
Hampshire preservation for Alliance yes
thank you very much um members of the
committee for uh hearing me today I'm
Jennifer Goodman the executive director
of the New Hampshire preservation
Alliance the Statewide historic
preservation nonprofit and I'll I'll
just add a very short portrait to the
point about the portrait we certainly uh
support this bill um I think as Senator
Waters alluded to if you look around um
the state you see so many ways that the
preservation that um former Senator
Martha Fuller Clark has uh shaped and
enhanced um our state and our
communities um and my um I think I'm
just representing one of many different
sectors and many different parts of of
the state and uh the disciplines where
she made a difference
um if you look around and are enjoying
rural Landscapes Old Farms and barns
vibrant Villages or downtowns restored
and reused Community landmarks you see
the work of Martha Fuller Clark as a
state senator and a state representative
she was an early and effective leader in
helping fellow legislators understand
historic preservation strategies and
their benefits and acting to improve
policies and sort of the toolkit around
historic preservation the list of her
legislative achievements is varied and
far-reaching and she forged really
important relationships and connections
to agriculture Economic Development
housing and conservation over her
legislative career to get that work done
so we feel that this portrait will honor
her great work and her Legacy and remind
future generations to advocate for that
special character and and economic
benefits associated with things like
historic preservation things that make
new Hampshire is so special for its
residents and its visitors so thank you
and um happy to answer any questions and
we sounds like you'll support this bill
and you have our um great support for it
as well thank you for being here and
thank you for your testimony you say you
have 20 copies I do uh could you hand
those out please and thank you for all
the information you added um I just wish
we saw I've seen it but I wish the other
members could currently see the portrait
thank you very much for being here
yes dncr stands for the Department of
Natural and cultural resources within
the state um
thank you committee members for
accepting this testimony um on behalf of
dncr um regarding Senate bill 331a um to
certain historic commemorations I'd like
to speak to the commemorative bottle
portion of the bill um my name is Matt
Flanders I'm the director of the Bureau
of historic sites for the State of New
Hampshire um we oversee Fort
constitution in Newcastle New Hampshire
um I also serve as the chair of the
cester Centennial commission currently
um the commission was established in
2022 under hb1 1441 it's charged with
organizing arranging and coordinating
tributes to the American Revolution
culminating with a publicized event on
July 4th
2026 um relating to the Declaration of
Independence uh in 2023 Senate Bill 103
added to the commission's planning
activities the raid on Fort William and
Mary which is now for constitution um
through a publicized event this December
14th 2024 um um the bill will enable the
commission to collaborate with the
Liquor Commission to manufacture commor
commemorative bottles to celebrate the
250th anniversary
um uh of the Revolution under the liquor
commission's historical fund program in
RSA 177 col 8 um the proceeds from the
sale of the commemorative bottles will
be deposited in the uh cester Centennial
trust fund to help support the work of
the commission um
uh thank you for allowing me to provide
this testimony and I'm open to any
questions if you have
any thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions or
comments from the committee
yes thank you for taking my question and
thank you for being here today I'm just
curious what what are the new bottles
going to look like I don't know that I
think the Liquor Commission might design
those and I only heard that just during
signer waterers testimony but I I don't
know that we're taking an active role in
the design we're happy to if um if
invited to but um we haven't gotten
there yet I think I think this bill will
start that process potentially makes
sense thanks thank you are there any
other questions or concerns from the
committee thank you very much and again
thank you for the information you added
today thank you is there anyone else who
wants to testify
today there being none we're closing the
hearing and thank you very much and we
are done thank you
hey Rich do you need to see
me yeah if you want to hang around a few
minutes to see if he comes back um
because he said he would be back the
work schedule was listed in the calendar
but we don't see it but he's not seeing
yeah but I just don't want to make that
U announcement for him yeah I would hate
for him to come back and have an empty
room break yeah take a break everybody
and
um microphone
can't I was just saying just before we
leave I would like to gauge a little bit
of everyone's sentiment on the the first
bill we heard in relation to we we did a
lot of work on the uh the previous
ethics Bill and
so I'm I'm a little bit like are we
going to do we take this one and we have
to leave that one are we P do we do we
like both of these like I don't just
where are you guys at with with it in
terms
of did we hold on to that bill I can't
remember if we no we passed it on
consent okay so the Senate has it okay
we passed it um what was it 15 to zero I
think we have one I couldn't remember if
we had passed it or
not this lays out some specific criteria
which I think is really good that yeah
exactly is it we'd have to look and see
if it kind of like a combination so we
could pass
both to the floor the house it's already
to the Senate it's already to the Senate
yeah so I don't know what their plans
are with it maybe we could work it
together in the committee of conference
or
yeah oh he was talking about the ethics
yeah the first
bill the answer to
that can you can you talk with the rich
and see if he might know the answer yeah
he's really smart and he knows a lot did
you hear any of our conversation you can
certainly sit at the microphone at least
we can all hear each other sorry sorry
to put you on the spot but you're up on
this stuff house bill is um for the
Senate it's been assigned to the
executive Department's Administration
committee yeah and there there's no
hearing set yet yeah
but in terms of how these two imagining
we pass both of these would these two
marry up pretty well or are we GNA have
to choose one over the other you know
what I mean this is very this is much
more specific and much more narrow
whereas the that our house bill was a
little more broad you know it's how
would these two meshes really what my
question is and do we have to do
anything with this Bild to mesh them
together
that well all sorts of things can happen
like that including Committees of
conference so um that's a policy
decision I don't think I should comment
on it it could happen what what is
really good about this bill is that you
know there are many moving Parts with
our ethics Provisions there are two
statutes there are the guidelines and
there's 32 years of precedent in
decisions and opinions and so if you
make a lot of
changes there can be unintended
consequences in fact there will
be and this does not doesn't do anything
to affect other parts of our Provisions
so the whole disclosure system stays in
place and you know we've been educating
legislators on how that works for all
this time and so all this would do is at
another level very nly defined for
recusal and so for example on these
examples of firefighters or retirement
system members and so
forth disclosure would still come into
place in all those circumstances where
it wouldn't rise to the level required
for start at this you would so if you're
in the retirement system and you've made
that disclosure on the January form as
we call it the beginning of the B
you wouldn't have to do anything more in
terms of disclosure unless it affects
you more than
others then if you get to a level where
you are involved as I understand this
with being with
the part of their time assistant that
might do lobbying then that's when this
will come into place and on the landlord
tenant situation if you were part of the
lobbying organization that the Real
Estate Association or whatever they call
it um then that would fall into the
place here in terms of RS otherwise if
you're a landlord you would file that
disclosure in in the January filing the
financial disclosure
form so it leaves all of that into in
place and and I I could Envision adding
one part of the Declaration of intent
form to have a box for I'm I'm required
to
recuse that way it doesn't create any
more paperwork
either and you need something like that
on the house of senate floor if you're
not going to you know you're not going
to post that's amazing testimony you
should type that up and and send it in
as an opinion and before you go I'm
sorry before you go on though back on
the landlord tenant thing
disclosure um disclosure is enough um
over the years we've heard that and we
did have this on Judiciary we had a lot
of landlords it seemed that they were
not disclosing that they were landlords
but through the Great Vine we heard what
would be the process say so members know
for disclosure it stays in place now
which is
that if you're participating in verbal
advocacy you're required currently to
say before a committee or on the floor
um I am a landlord there's no greater
you know you don't have to go on and on
about it I am a landlord that's the
verbal disclosure and so the other
disclosure should already have occurred
on the financial disclosure form
and if a bill is going to affect you
more than other landlords then you will
have to file the Declaration intent
form in terms of recusal you would
probably have to be a member of the New
Hampshire realer Association which does
lobbying you have to be paid by
them so there'll be no change in terms
of
that okay and going to a represent
attorney's concern about
selectman my former concern as a former
selectman um if we had an issue this is
just hypothetical years ago select milon
communities were able to find out and
they still do ahead of time who hasn't
paid their taxes on their property and
after three years um that can what is
the term I've lost it
now put a lean on it yeah and some
Selectmen in some towns were buying
those properties only for taxes becoming
landlords or turning around and selling
them and actually we heard today um the
term was used um bear with me the term
was
used people enriching themselves and
Selectmen in some towns were enriching
themselves we now have a law that
prevents them from doing that
um I'm thinking if there are other bu
that might come before the house such
as oh I don't know placing a landfill
somewhere in the town and a landlord
excuse me a selectman I'm sorry a
selectman wants it as far away from his
property as he or she could get it uh
would have some influence on that
shouldn't
they then consider
recusing this person as a legislator
you're speaking about also uh well
currently there would be a disclosure
issue under this I it's the three-part
requirement and so they would have to
also be uh involved with um their
organization lobbying testifying or
otherwise attempting to influence the
legislative
activity see this is this is where my
question comes in because I think in our
other bill it puts it much closer to
they would have to recuse whereas this
one would be clear would you would it's
all of the above you have to do one it's
very narrow it's very narrow in scope
and and where our other bill I think is
much more uh Broad and potentially would
have to refused so that's why I'm
wondering how we're going to figure out
the two bills measur question before we
go on Jen um this is all really good
discussion I don't know if it's being
recorded or not if you stop recing
because we' we've moved into a work
session
okay oh good because I was wondering I'm
not taking notes but it's all really
good information so I just I can go back
later and type it up and put it in the
notes if you want okay so we'll just say
work session continued yeah that's good
thank you go
ahead question okay it says on line nine
receives uh Financial remuneration from
the organization I get paid by the town
$100 a meeting for 2400 bucks a year
that's it holds a position to exercise
substantial influence over the Affairs
I'm chairman of the board of
Selectmen now the organization has
lobbied testified or otherwise attempted
to influence the outcome of the official
legislative activity the town of
Northumberland belongs to the New
Hampshire Municipal Association which uh
does Lobby did I just fit all three of
those
criteria maybe I think um it was um
representative Lynn who suggested of
putting a dollar amount in there perhaps
too okay because the way it's written
now since we belong to
nhma I believe I fill all three of those
up not to mention when you go down
further I'm obviously a voting member of
the governing body but are you an
employee of the M Hampshire Municipal
Association I think that is prop we're
me we're a member but you personally no
not personally the town is because it
says a
legislator um receives Financial reation
from the
organization I think in that case
they're referring your example you'd be
referring to the municipal associ as the
organization which is doing the lobbying
okay and I think that falls within the
hierarchy that uh Representative Bob Lyn
was talking about in terms of being an
Adjunct professor as opposed to being a
Chancellor for a university system um
being a select member we you are um at
sorry a lower level of that hierarchy
and you're only a member of the
municipal Association again you're not
paid by the municipal Association you're
paid by your town right that so you're
safe if you look at it one way it
bus every single yeah I I find that
interesting we might want to look at the
wording of that um just for a little
further clarification I think that makes
sense that yeah no to look at this and
and go for further clarification in in
terms of how we want this draft to yes
Rich did you have something to add to
that because you would have to be an
employee either way I see this of the
entity which is doing the
lobbying yeah
and
you and you do vote for the budget you
establish the budget and you vote for it
and you vote for uh putting money into
that membership organic work session
okay you want us to go back up
no so um
we
[Music]
just asked so what do you guys think
this and then
we got some really good feedback from
Rich Lambert which um so we I doubt that
we confirmed that I'm gonna type this
all up as a work session and the notes
but I don't I'm gonna have to go back
yeah yeah that's that's the benefit of
the YouTube tape isn't it yes thank you
very much representative wall for
stepping in um just so everyone's aware
um we went down and testified on the in
Senate Edna on the legislative youth
advisory Council bill that they were
going to exact they held off waiting for
us so we kind of had
to they didn't because in the middle of
it um Senator Carson left and
so yeah I anyway I'm on I'm on tape um
FYI so did we did um as far as the the
605 Bill did we hear
anything that the reason I I set up the
work session after this um and I would
have hoped there was a lot more people
here but I guess what I'm looking for is
are there things that you heard in that
hearing that
um makes us want to get additional
information
Andor um look at different options for
this um we have our very fine researcher
here which is always helpful but in this
particular case if there are things I
have no idea for example I have no idea
what the
IRS um language is that they referenced
in here and and I don't think our
researcher does either um I really
wouldn't have even gone to the IRS to to
look for that I don't know why anyone
would I don't know this is but that's
why I wanted to find out if there were
are things like that that we should look
at before we go I also want to know just
for a second I also want to know um and
maybe this is a a Jennifer
thing what what
does our existing language that's in the
Senate now how would that be affected by
what came here I don't know that answer
um so that's what I that's why I
suggested we do this work session so
that we kind of come to a an
understanding so we all are un knowing
what certain things are doing um but
there's also no reason why we can't have
another work session before we exact
these two um my goal is to hang on to
these things for a while so and let them
mold I don't think it's a problem if if
we my my question is can these work
together because there're little this is
much more narrow in scope it's very
specific and all that and does this
committee as um and I would say on
consent sort of situation do we like one
bill over the other and we shouldn't
wait that long because if we don't like
this and we like our bill well maybe we
should kill hurry up and kill this thing
and and then you leave it with the only
the Senate to have our bill I know
that's a little bit of politics but that
that's the the body that we are in and
if it's not though if we can get both of
these sort of passing then maybe it's
committee a conference then where we can
figure out how we get it then then the
pressure is off and we can work on it
and that sort of thing so absolutely
true I don't disagree with any of that
thank you and um talking with
representative TIY I we may need further
clarification because he tell me if I'm
wrong we talked about um those three
criteria and each one of them matches
what he does as a select and I'm not
inmore so it doesn't matter to me but um
talked about person having substantial
influence as a selectman and we talked a
little bit about that wondered if there
might need to be some clarification on
the language just to be sure um that
select me or not affected and we did get
clarification the fact that the
selectman do pay into the New Hampshire
Municipal Association but do not have a
direct influence necessarily on what
they decide um and it seems to fit in
with the criteria that um I hope this is
not being recorded um it
seems okay you want to talk about it
later
um just him with the criteria that um
the hierarchy that represent Lynn talked
about in terms of a professor an Adent
Professor not having the same position
and power of authority as the chancellor
for University system a selectman has a
power of authority at certain levels but
uh with the municipal Association um
only a membership of one of over 200
communities or municipalities rather in
the state so there's that difference but
that we may need uh further
clarification on language just so that
others who aren't familiar with this uh
would understand it
better um let me ask if if this is of
help to any of you because I'm I'm able
to provide all of it if you would like
um
I I um bothered a number of people to
provide me with pieces of information
one of which was the testimony that took
place in the Senate on this bill um
there was some language there that is
kind of helpful I think there was also
the the information that came from the
draft minutes of the Ethics Committee
who talked about
um let me just back up a second you
realize this bill and I think she said
it this
bill um as came as a result of the
opinion given to Senator Carson's
request for an opinion right so that
discussion of how they determined how
the Ethics Committee came up with their
reasoning steered this um this Duo of of
Susi and Bradley to come up with this
bill or they asked their Senate attorney
to to do that so so there is some
interesting conversation that went on
they're not even sure and and this is
here's the guy that took the notes in
that committee but but my understanding
of those minutes
were they really weren't
sure which section applied but they both
agreed why they
were um not to recuse they weren't sure
under they disagreed on which section
applied to the to the situation but but
that's that's a microcosm of how
confusing this is if they can't
decide how this works how the heck is
the guy in division three in the middle
of the row gon to decide that's my
problem all along in all of this and I
also think um here is the
analysis this is this was confusing to
me this is the computer uh the committee
analysis on that bill and and there was
a line that said they clearly are unable
to exercise substantial influence over
the Affairs of those
organizations they're Senators um and
and they are instructors within the
university system so are we
now it seems like we're dancing on the
head of a pin um are we now worried
about how big organization is Are We Now
worried about what their position within
that organization is Are We Now worried
about their ability to influence actions
if that organization comes here it
is and and and where is the line drawn
if you're not worried about it I mean
Everyone likes to bring up the idea of
the janitor versus the CEO but there's a
lot lot of positions in between there
and and I don't think anyone and I don't
know that this legislation I'll have to
look at it more closely but I don't know
if anyone has told me where that where
that line Falls that this is a problem
this
isn't and that's
hard yes you have some very strong
points
and always have questions I don't have
points I have yeah concerns concern um
yeah and that's where I am at this point
too because as I listen to testimony
today I heard that it's really up to the
individual to determine which is throws
us right back to where we have been
right we're not moving forward we're not
getting as you said that clear line of
on the walk up we don't know yep I it
seems the more we delve into this the
deeper the questions and it does seem to
come down to that line in the of
um circumstances um for each individual
case well how does that help a
legislator who's trying to before they
even become a legislator if they're
trying to decide whether to run and they
are handed this booklet and say Here's
all you need to know about whether
you're going to be able to vote on the
things that are important to
you I don't think they you're going to
have that ability to do that from that
book all right
I don't really need monkey monkey
wrenches right really this way we're not
looking at yet that way is the
perception of the public we are
wondering about strictly on everything
we're talking about is the perception we
have for fellow
members we should actually be looking
more at how do they perceive theu
and if they're not as bothered by
it why the heck are we that terribly
bothered by I mean no I I disagree I I
think it is important very important to
understand their level uh or their
perspective but my personal ethics don't
change based on whether somebody else
thinks it's a problem here it to mind
find don't change even by what's written
in
this that is somebody's that is
somebody's or some organization's
opinion and strictly that an
opinion uh you signed on to that I
signed onto it doesn't mean I believe
100% in it uh there are things right but
getting back to your idea of whether it
matters it does matter what the public
perceives right but
it but that doesn't change whether it
even if they are not I still think this
is an important issue for us
to to review what I'm saying what I'm
getting at is maybe I misunderstood this
thing
here is 68 pages
long to me as far as EIC gos that's way
too big that's way too digging down
as you can get yeah I tried to give it a
real simple thing and and it got
summarily
killed Mr Lambert I do think that we
should produce another type of booklet
that's the the idea is to have
everything relating to the Ethics
Committee and ethics laws and rules in
that book in one place but that includes
the procedural rules which no one needs
to look at unless you're the unfortunate
party in a
complaint and it has two statutes and it
has the guidelines a lot of which
overlap and repeat and so there should
be something shorter that members should
have with them you'd mentioned having
um and I have tried to work on that some
but um but something much much
shorter perhaps maybe only the
guidelines and some summary of The Gift
provisions of 14c which is something I
do produce for
orientation but and that's just a print
out there should be some sort of booklet
that would be smaller in format that and
and the members could carry with them
which would tell them when they need to
recuse when they need to disclose what's
an illegal gift that sort of
thing no I don't disagree I I
um I like the one page idea um you know
I we we tried originally to whittle that
down to one page and basically said if
you think it's a problem it is and and
if you're related to anybody that has
that this is causing you a reason to
change your vote that's a problem um and
both of those were
sarily uh tossed in the in the waste can
by the Ethics Committee so
um
I I'm hard pressed to think that we're
GNA come up with the solution that H
pleases everyone I actually
think what we are coming up to is a is
and what we're creating not only with
the bill that we pass through uh the
house but also this one I think what we
have is really something that they are
going to use for adjudication purposes
not as something that is going to help
our fellow legislators or even potential
future legislators that are trying to
figure out if they would have ethical
issues coming here I don't think that's
somehow possible um but but is there
anything that um let's just try to focus
on this bill is there anything that that
we either need to research other than
this IRS the idea that it comes from the
IRS and why and and
and whether
that's providing us any Keys um I
started telling you what I had for
information I can certainly give you the
um this the information I've been given
which is the um uh information from
House Council who who provid us the
draft minutes of of the Ethics Committee
um we also have what else do we have
Jennifer
um yep the hearing report from the
Senate that was kind of that was just a
front and back of a piece of paper um
their hearing was um one 15if of what
our hearing just was I mean there was
only one person that testified and it
was Senator Susi and and they asked I
don't know 10
questions if that so um
I um I don't know what other things that
you would like to know about um but I'm
happy to get you copies of any of
that you're in a you're in a unique
position because you've already seen
you've already had these arguments times
two um yeah I no looking at this bill
and all I I think they do try to bring
us forward again the focus of the bill
is the organization for the purposes of
recusal so that's where this whole
hierarchy thing comes in and that helps
to clarify some I don't know if we're
ever really going to get to
where I mean it's been years years of
struggling with the legislature on the
Ethics Committee to try to come up with
simple definitions you can't do this you
can't do that and we can't quite put our
finger on it I think this comes
closer uh when you look at the language
is definitely simpler in this yeah it is
um but but here again we're already
pointing to things in this um that well
why not the Selectmen you've gone you
know you're exempting these people but
you're not exempting selectman why why
not um
what and one of the things that was
brought up was in terms of how much of
the fact that you're paid to do a
certain position but a concern that
represent attorney has and I have as
well is the influence the power cuz
Selectmen have tremendous influence and
power if they want to
yeah um and and I that's why I was
trying to broaden it it's selectman is
one
example
um I you can't believe how much power in
a in an area the fire chief has um when
you get down to all of the inspections
of different things um it's enormous
much more so than a fire than a select
one as far as I'm concerned and not only
that if you do not have a building
inspector code enforcement that's the
chief right well this is what autom goes
down to them well this is what I'm
saying so it's
not to to completely this bill
completely ignores
that
um I think thank you Mr chair and I
think it brings us forward as I said but
we hadn't even thought of Fire Chiefs
and but you're right and again it's a
hierarchy in each uh municipality who
has what power well they're exempting
these people yeah but they didn't exempt
Fire Chiefs and that's that's right
um but I
likeis yeah that that makes more sense
that covers everything going down
municipalities the fire departments the
police department the water district all
those things picked up yeah don't forget
you also have the sewer
Commissioners who could forget the Sewer
Commission come on
Alison
um that's kind of what this is all about
actually you um I don't
um I don't
I don't know um I are we headed to a
committee of conference on this do you
think
um just not there yet I'd love to know
Rich sorry no I I think he's having I I
don't want to almost put him in the
position to have to do this talk but can
I just say one thing the Ethics
Committee meets on Monday and the on the
agenda is discussion of these two bills
the two ethics bills that's true so
Monday 1:00 Monday I think I'll be in
the audience until you go into
non-public and I leave again probably
there will be three non-public sessions
before we get to so it'll be 2 o'clock
maybe okay I could call
you unless I'm the the subject of one of
those I don't know
um but um I don't
uh I I guess what I would like is for
for all of you and anyone else that's
listening um
to
offer ways of of um either simplify this
is pretty simple this part but but how
do we express this to if your colleague
asks what are you doing on ethics what
are you you going to say to them you
know how
does it seems that we have no limit to
the number of questions even even the
answers that someone has got in an
opinion is turning back into more
questions and coming back to ethics so
um I I don't know I mean it it get it
seemingly gets to even what your title
is within an
organization
um and I don't know it seem it didn't
seem like our version of this dealt as
much with the employer
employee I thought we handled that
pretty well the employer employee
relationship this seems to only deal
with that employer or employee
relationship um but not with you know if
your brother is a contractor and you're
in here voting on New Roads and that's
going to benefit him this doesn't say
anything about
that so I don't
know think of things that we need to do
and communicate through Vanessa or I um
for now I guess I'm gonna ask Jen to
just look at what that if you can find
out from maybe Rick Layman what what the
um the IRS portion of this and how
relates and beyond that is there any
other suggestions anyone
has what SE of
this 14 C2 isn't it 14 C2 or4
so I no no no I think it is
14c I thought this was 14 C2 it might be
14 C4 they
both this creates new
sections it didn't it
didn't to the same section to the same
chapter 14
right or if or it right
yeah okay thanks everyone for coming
and you get extra
pay you get all the pay of everybody
that isn't
here um I am a little upset that our new
M it wasn't
here well I know but you think you were
just appointed to a committee You' think
you would be here I hope she understand
hope she's not down in 104 waiting for
us or something you know scare her
off what's
say
e
e for